le versailles éric bellion est l'un des
novices sur ce vendée globe 2016 le
skipper est en mer depuis 56 jours soit
bien fait en légèreté navigue en étant
prudent mais hélas le bateau guide bien
vu les bonnes conditions ah oui c'est
chouette hein pour participer à son
premier tour du monde en solitaire et
sans escale éric bellion a eu besoin de
mécènes pour financer un bateau à
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
et l'équipement dernière génération
installé à bord ces derniers se
réunissent tous les quinze jours à paris
pour débriefer l'avancée du navigateur
eric il est tenu par 14 mai scène ils
permettent un projet de vivre et
en fait la différence entre le mécénat
et sponsoring c'est que les baisses est
beaucoup ils n'ont pas leurs noms sur le
bateau ou les isolants non mais dans une
moindre mesure est en fait ils ont ils
sont fédérés autour d'eric et autour des
valeurs que porte erika parmi ces 14
personnes on retrouve la société celle
force leader mondial des outils de
relation client l'entreprise a investi
près de 900000 euros sur trois ans pour
accompagner le navigateur dans son
périple à douze éléments et sociale
d'abord l'homme eric et son parcours et
sa façon de raconter cette histoire la
sincérité qu'il dégage et ensuite à à
titre égal j'aurais tendance à dire les
valeurs et les valeurs de son projet
quand la raison le coeur se rejoignent
et bien c'est arrivé ensuite il a fallu
en interne que
que je combats quelques quelques idées
reçues parce que tout le monde était
d'accord avec moi mais personne ne
voulait me donner l'argent sans pareil à
la fin j'ai réussi à trouver l'argent et
on a mis tout le monde d'accord
au plus grand bonheur des rébellions qui
espère désormais terminé son tour du
monde en solitaire d'ici le mois de
février